it's been an exciting week for CNN
Russian collusion is still a lie they
spent two years tying the country but
they finally got someone to leak
information on Donald Trump's taxes from
30 years ago that information showed
that Trump lost money people in network
were excited about this this is CNN
tonight I'm Don Lemon are you listening
the President of the United States is a
fraud and a conman you were saying he's
a sociopath without any question a con
all of it all of it was a con you know
this person is a walking fraud calls
people losers and he has such disdain
and and yet he was literally the biggest
loser in the country so if you remember
the 90s you might recall that trumps
business problems were a big news story
they were real from put a book about
them don't tell Don LeMond he was
shocked you know what they say about
gambling casino gambling right the house
always wins well not always
not if it's a Trump casino because I'm
good enough smart enough and doggone
people love me
one of the odds at Don Lemon says that
in the mirror every morning hi Joe
Concha writes about media for the hill
and he joins us tonight Joe great to see
you tonight
so this didn't so they basically
discovered that Trump lost a ton of
money in the 90s which anyone who was
alive then knew because it was a major
story but this was news because why why
because it was presented as recycled
news I don't like you used to term fake
news Tucker but in this case you could
have read Donald Trump's book from 2007
the art of the comeback you could have
read any of the New York tabloids that
New York Daily News New York Post talked
about the Trump slump for those years
between 1985 1994 you could have watched
The Apprentice season 1 episode 1 the
very first segment Donald Trump
literally says on video that he lost
billions of dollars he was billions in
debt and he was able to come back so to
keep all of that out of reporting if we
want to call this even reporting that is
the bias of omission we've talked about
that before and that is the worst kind
of bias because if you were say younger
or you didn't follow Donald Trump or you
live out of the bubble you're taking
care of your kids every day and you're
working hard and you come home and you
hear this story about Trump losing
billions back at that time and you don't
get the other side of the story which is
he was very transparent about it on TV
books you're being sold a bill of goods
here that this was new revelation when
it was anything but new Tucker yeah I
mean this this this was his whole story
right I mean this was I mean he bragged
about it endlessly
you know once was lost now him found
this was his Redemption story did you
hear anybody covering this pause for a
moment to say a little weird that we're
looking at private financial information
that's supposed to be proprietary I mean
no one is supposed to have this
information did anyone say that kind of
a violation of privacy no no Tucker it
no one does it because it's a means to
an end right I remember I was on your
show and we talked about the Access
Hollywood tape and everybody
concentrated and rightly so the contents
of it but then there was another part of
that story which is hugs
actly did that tape gets out of NBC and
into the hands of the Washington Post
two days before a presidential debate a
major one three weeks before an election
no one bothered to look into that and no
one's gonna bother to look into the fact
that this was leaked by somebody
confidential information and it got into
the hands of the New York Times and
obviously was spread everywhere and by
the way and I get that Don Lemon he's on
at night and there are a lot of opinions
at night but he still billed as an
anchor and for him to talk that way and
act that way and I've been on Don's show
and he's a great guy in person but I can
never picture Bret Baier or Chris
Wallace or Jeff Glor or David Muir ever
acting like that and their anchors also
so you wonder why CNN struggles and you
want to hear about struggles to Tucker
so in cable news they rank obviously all
the shows by ratings and you got to get
down the number 36 out of Fox and MSNBC
and CNN number 36 to find the
highest-rated
CNN show in other words the other 35 are
the other two networks so they have to
understand they're alienating their
viewers by acting like children on the
air but they're not doing it I don't
understand why when the results are so
horrible from a business perspective
because it's a political mission I think
that's I think that's it joke on ship
great to see you tonight
thank you for that happy Mother's Day
happy weekend happy weekend